I’m constantly amazed how many women think feminism is a good thing
women have been so lied to
feminism was created to separate family
we valued our sense of independence so much
that it took away our strong sense of family unit
Kids are being raised by government child care
women are working just as many hours as the men are
but are still expected to go home and take care of their children
it's a 24/7 job to be a woman living in America
this isn't the American dream
the American dream is living off of one income
The man provide and we depend on them
The American Dream would be woman taking care of themselves,
the home, their children,
their husband
Women are meant to be gardening,
cooking good food,
nurturing the ones that they love.
That's when women get a strong sense of self
and when they're in their true feminine energy
that's when they thrive
you cannot convince me that women were meant to work a 9 to 5 job
just like a man is
you see other women being taken care of
maybe they're cooking
they're taking care of the children and they're being there present
and you think wow,
I would love that
when a woman is in her soft feminine era
she thrives and that's what any woman wants
sSociety has brainwashed us to think independence is a good thing
when in reality it just breaks families apart
now don't get me wrong
I think feminism can be a good thing (supporting women)
but I just feel like it shouldn't have come at the cost of
losing the family unit
nobody has a strong sense of family
and why is that?
I would strongly suggest that feminism,
independence women girl bossing a little too hard
took away the strong urgency of having a family